thanks to her the liquor
and student committee thank you very much
mina we will say goodbye afterwards so
let me focus for the moment
on the agenda so hello to all first of
all here is the agenda of the
president airlines for  the coming week
starting on sunday 1
december the president will take part in an
event
at the house of european history
to celebrate the entry into force of the
lisbon treaty in the company of
mr david st solid president of the
european parliament
mr charles michel president  of the
european council and madame christine
lagarde president of the european central bank
then on tuesday 2 december the
president will deliver a speech at
the opening session of the
cop 25 conference on
climate change organized by the
united nations in madrid on wednesday
this train will be held  the first meeting
of the college of the commission at the fender
hatred and as usual we will
give you more details
at the beginning of next week finally
note that the president will go Saturday,
December 7 to addis ababa in ethiopia
she will meet there in particular the
president of  the commission of the
african union mr moussa faki as well as
the ethiopian prime minister and
nobel peace prize mr habib ahmed
thank you i will see if there are still
really urgent questions for
today for héricourt for us
before we go  address a little more
personally no questions even
if the room is full do well ok
thank you eric islam has been validated
here is an impressive victory fires
of your life
it put skate family 3 o'clock
and cry for every day from a  new
elsewhere
an analytical political criticism
continues the worst for capital in western
corniche
it is with very strong emotions
time
living in
[Applause]
a small one which goes michel carlier and
[Music]
spaces
[Applause]
coli for spring 2009
[Applause  ]
adam silver from salary weather that
burned on the lake
[Applause]
no today is the day
of farewell or goodbye to our colleagues
from the juncker team spp
from the nkr team it is impossible
to compete with the words  which
have just been pronounced by mines and
natacha in glass plush i would
simply like to express to them on behalf of dana
of the transition team of the
president and mine all our
gratitude for the unfailing support
that she herself and all the  spt team
provided us during this
transition period which is coming to an end,
we absolutely could not have done
our work without your support
and as I already had the opportunity to
say to myself this morning in an atmosphere not
only very  professional but
also very friendly very human very
warm and I believe that this is
something exceptional and that we
will try to continue as the
succession team of the spp of the current aspect
so thank you thank you once again
I hope you will be able  to have
from Saturday evening a little bit
calmer now as far as we are
concerned I am afraid that indeed
things will change a little I would
also like to tell you I am very happy to
see you here in the press room
so many today for the
President Juncker's last press conference I hope to see you
as many on
Monday at noon for our first
meeting of 2010 of course we will be in the
start-up phase
there will certainly be
things to work out but I am
you can be  assured that on our
side we will make every effort
to be able to provide you with the best
service for
target and contribute to the best
possible coverage of
European affairs in the European media and beyond
thank you again and to the eel a
non
valet
le cuir
[  Applause]
welcome mr president att of
the yellow west us food and drug
stores at the top of new way is because
then to play who denies any case of a
guy is a man of weight your level
of the ass of all  must lift the demo
of mouthe doubs with this fish respect
meech there must not exist behind these
two say to each other almost like i
said i'm not the goodbye man
i happen to cry i've already
cried a lot and  that's enough
but I would like to tell you that I leave
the head of the commission
with two elements satisfaction rate
with a few many regrets but
I am happy to leave because
being chairman of the commission is a
task that is not the easiest  because
I did a book
two years ago, like at the different
jobs in the wat, and I said to myself, here it
must be the secretary general of
the UN,
but we are doing so much the book, I discover
that it was the breaking point of the commission
that  was targeted by this registration a
bit stupid more than 200 euros me I
really liked working with the press
I don't know the number of meetings
that we knew there are many
18 press conference in your this
room 150 a few
he presented himself  press conference
in the common vip 150 interviews and
so I know that I put you in the
dark condition that you would not have
liked but I do not think that the word
has an influence on what it is
rare and if we know  already that every day
if we this site is even every day what
I like to do because you find
all the same to have been able to have taken a
language which was quite understandable we
began to annoy the others so I
wanted to thank you for this long
road  that we made together a
capacity moselle reports from hasparren
may 19 in particular is becoming rarer I see
that escapes because my zmorda this
south ige world is negative the most beautiful joke
only the presidency in the name of eta
level things work on  the
internship before ten years now it will be
well 10
the gaullists who face the
sweet needs on Thursday correspond to an
article of the bourg europa and not remove
sheep and inhabitants in
short of aces in its walls of ice all
missing from the flash and able  to
manage at the level of beating the eyes of
our site
in this gentleman is not done I said
gillis more always than the euro and
myself I believe that it mine al minah
the recovery and I always confuse the
two d  'her because they are excluded
mambo even to the same degree because
I was putting an approach
and a man I still don't know
what world I'm going here we speak
several languages ​​you never know in
which novel rif and from  anyway i'm
too stupid for hip hop or my
memories of dreams that couldn't be
mine besides ribéry rather nice
to see that dreams aren't
subject to the dictatorship of
transparency
i've often said that l  'euro and I we
were the only survivors of very
vast buying the euro will be alone I think
the president has not here today to
give world jazz
there will be cheeseman his president offered
two commissions at night to all who
combine in woippy where  michael x you
but she goes to the different
opinions are 10th correspondence is
nobody will have to get jean claude
juncker or so tomorrow i'll come back to it leed
for homes to the tortillas of the
difficulty line in montauban
we found our ministers don't
even have anything  that in 2010 nicosia yes this
year before the important place
idriss review nobody else has been so
committed inconstant the idea of ​​kate and
the european project the
european construction as the founding father
peace is always at the point public
police who arrive in 2  min 10 s
president jacques mignaux vase she is going to
preach from elsewhere commitments sows
returns democracy your consideration
ford press respects strongly prescribed in
certain personal broadcasts
outspoken human and emotional touch your
woman of power boat a text in this sense
everything 6 18
we do great yes  in nancy newmont molosses
a live pressure index of heavy
express delivery is we are here it was
going to seek in sauce the timing is a
very disgusting exception of the two
exceptions canada
goulet
granby laval are fighting three years from the
crash
in casting fr yes precisely on  the
last point daniel weder for the
luxembourgish public radio 100.7 you
said that you were in the
press room 18 times here five years ago
marguerite espinasse told us
during your premiere before your
first press conference that we had to  get
used to seeing
the president of the european commission more often
in the press room
so my question is what
held you back is what you were advised
not to appear too often to
avoid answers maybe a  little
too spontaneous that we know about you this is
my first question the second
question concerns your life from
2 monday or much earlier tuesday
you have you will have an office here in
the accommodation
you also have an office in luxembourg
or  are you going to be
working more often and what are
you going to do mainly thank you
since the first question daniel it
is true that I had thought that I would be
in the press room more often but in
fact I j  I sat down at the beginning but in
terms of ide continue fanning
to abolish myths and daily we
are the only practical organization
greedy where there is more confidence
every day
which means that
when we sometimes lose the essential in
communication
and then I had introduced a
condition management system that they wanted there to
be a first vice president
and vice president case in charge of
coordinating the activities of the
commissioners I had this rule all my
during the life of the ecpal and those who
worked I will not say that I am
not occupied with the files which were those
which animated the action of the commission
but if there is a vice president two vice
presidents and several commissioners who
work a  subject is on a subject
I preferred to let them speak for
instead of who you have you are all the cases
do all the performances
generally calm and then finally that I
told you often this is not the
only place where the  commission speaks to the
press
this is the only place where all of you
individually
show up regularly but in life
cry like there are also events
happening when i be the
president of albania or the prime
minister them  of crimes tallinn do
n't do our conferences from this
crisis room but we do it to
be happy okay so one all his
press conferences are worth and then
i gave a lot of interviews
are only 48
his almost 250 where i  speaks to the press
and to avis to the people
of europe and so I don't
feel like I have failed in but
channels of communication
if you add to all his
press briefings the press conferences that
I gave together with in everything
after the European Council
if you say so if you doubted it
all the speeches I made in the
European parliament
I am surprised that I did that so
often of my future life will be
elsewhere  valentino looking back at he
said
my part i'm doing i didn't suffer
style it's true there are already two
trophies and respect and audacity
first to be fun and just to
claw
then it was virginie madam of the world
in  the playbook today you
tell you an anecdote which we understand
that jacques chirac made you listen to
on your famous nokia and I would have
liked to know a little more than just one the
nokia of the time and is listenable the
nokia that  I have today to date from the
19th century no longer
because they exceed the
technical capacities of the various
secret services budgeted in paris
in 97 eur because I had made an
appointment with jacques des lots to prepare for
the summit  European employment office
I had appointed him special adviser
you have to do everything the same
it's extraordinary to have to
enter Luxembourg minister
asked a former president of the
commission to become his special adviser
together with others and I went to
see him  at his house he told me okay there you
will come to my house and we will discuss like
me I am a specialist in short
distances
I said to myself here I am in paris he
is in paris so I will be there in 20
minutes a gift but after that  took
an hour and a half couralet dumont
the lafontaine hotel or also
memories are accurate and so i had to
change hotels lodge was very surprised
that during the night i make you two or
three in the morning did not even
later bill clinton  calls me to
tell me about a problem between airbus and
boeing
ninon you suspect and I was very
surprised that he found me in this hotel
which called me on the landline
the landline of the hotel while  '
themselves delegations did not know that
I had changed hotels but therefore the
president of the united states knew it and
I was very surprised the next day
when jacques chirac welcomed me on
the steps of the elysée palace let's not say the way
you answered clinton this is the
way workers should talk
to americans
so i thought to myself here is
fabius saw the dude we will do all my
stack cause said this model all formula
feed lots of pools in
zurich have a  high point it is
said again this morning there are guys like
sportsmen abstaining just like a
frame where the german world law kathrin
unfolds the story our tactics italy
d92 cold drop since the cold drops
jean claude trichet bank casino
antoine diot is cooked ministers all
levels  it's an american
since the ministers stop reading you
the top tweets of the notes
i also found that a little black dress
thank you look at what kevin m free to
the democratic crisis
ok you do another was below
crds but  aristocrat einstein dallaire
2 710 stine gry who have seen christophe
opposition differently
m
gueorgui yes hello sir
it seems to me that here
you are and you will be the
first the last game pixels candidate
what do you think about the idea of ​​leading
campaign in 2014
I have a long time I am a candidate I
guess the idea of ​​not repeating it in
2019 makes a mistake I
never know the pixi candidates again I like this
unique situation of having been the only one who
did not  there was no successor in this role
but I tell you that it is a regret
all the same that I must express
it was a very small democratic advance
we removed its cost for obscure reasons
I have to worry about the stables of f1
[Applause]
lee
so
in the roof
yes force though the bubbles man to
ladies
[Music]
no
and if they like
ok ok [
Music] [
Applause] [
Applause]
[Applause]
that will do
it comes in two
[Music]